en este vídeo haré a la demostración del
teorema del residuo para polinomios y
para que no resulte tan abstracta
empezaré revisando el ejemplo que
hicimos cuando presentamos el teorema
del residuo para polinomios vimos que sí
teníamos 3x cuadrada menos 4 x 7 y lo
dividimos entre x menos uno obteníamos
3x menos 1 y un residuo de 6 y nos dimos
cuenta que este era el residuo pues el
orden de este término es menor al orden
que tenemos aquí en el denominador y
todo esto ocurrió después de haber hecho
la división larga de este numerador
entre el denominador de tal manera que
en este ejemplo podríamos haber escrito
esto que hicimos aquí como nuestra fx
voy a ponerlo por aquí nuestra fx que es
3x cuadrada menos 4 x más 7 es igual al
producto de estos dos términos al
producto de este cociente por el
denominador esto es igual al producto de
este cociente el cociente que es 3x
menos 1 que multiplica al denominador
que multiplica
- 1 y esto aún no está completo pues
cuando multiplicas estos dos términos no
obtienes esto de acá hay que sumarle a
esto el residuo esto más el residuo r no
mejor voy a poner directamente el valor
del residuo 6 esto de aquí es análogo a
lo que teníamos cuando hacíamos las
divisiones en aritmética así si
tuviéramos la división de digamos voy a
mostrarte directamente la analogía si
tenemos por ejemplo la división de 25
entre
4 bien sabemos que 25 entre 4 es igual a
6 6 por 4 24 lo cual restamos de 25 para
obtener que el residuo es 1 entonces 25
lo podemos escribir de la siguiente
manera 25 es igual a 6 por 4 25 es igual
a 6
4 ya eso le sumamos el residuo más 1
esto que hicimos aquí es exactamente lo
mismo nada más que aquí lo estamos
haciendo con expresiones algebraicas aún
no entraba la demostración lo único que
he querido hacer es aclararte que cuando
nosotros dividimos entre x menos 13 x
coah - 4 x + 7 obtuvimos esto de aquí es
decir 3 x 4 menos 4 x + 7 es igual a 3 x
menos 1 x x menos uno más el residuo más
6 escribamos esto de manera abstracta
este término que tenemos aquí es nuestro
polinomio fx que es igual a 3 x menos 1
que en este caso es el cociente a este
cociente le voy a llamar q de x déjame
ponerlo con otro color este de aquí es q
de x
es un polinomio que le voy a llamar q de
x f x es igual a q de x que multiplica a
x menos 1 pero lo voy a llamar x menos a
pues lo estoy haciendo en general
así es que q de x que multiplica a x
menos a a lo cual le voy a sumar el
residuo r aquí sé que el residuo es un
número es una constante pues sé que su
orden es menor a x1 a x menos a que es
un polinomio de orden 1 con lo cual
tiene que ser un polinomio de orden 0 es
decir una constante esto que hemos
escrito aquí entonces es verdad en
general para cualquier polinomio fx
dividido entre cualquier x menos a vamos
a escribir eso aquí esto es verdadero
para todas
fx
para todas fx y para todas x menos a
ahora bien qué va a suceder cuando
nosotros evaluamos
efe de a qué ocurre al evaluar efe en a
en la expresión que acabamos de escribir
y que sabemos que siempre es verdadera
veámoslo tenemos que fedea aquí voy a
usar otro color para resaltar la a en la
cual estamos evaluando la función
entonces
efe de a efe de a es igual acude a
q evaluada en a
que multiplica
x más bien a a que multiplica a menos a
y creo que ya te estás dando cuenta a
que vamos a llegar que multiplica a a
menos a
+ r y ahora qué es lo que tenemos aquí a
menos a es cero no me importa cuánto
vale q de a porque lo voy a multiplicar
por 0 así es que todo este término se
cancela con lo cual llegamos a que f
ese día va a ser igual
r y ya la tenemos esta es la
demostración del teorema del residuo
para polinomios cualquier polinomio que
al dividirlo entre x menos a obtienes el
cociente q de x y el residuo r puedes
escribirlo de esta manera una vez que el
polinomio se tiene escrito de esta
manera al evaluarlo entonces en la vamos
a obtener que el polinomio evaluado en a
coincide exactamente con el residuo y
este es el teorema del residuo para
polinomios y así hemos concluido con una
de las demostraciones más simples de
algo que en un principio parece como
mágico